Dan: Hi YouTube.
This is Dan Shapiro from the Harvard International
Negotiation Initiative.
I'm also director of the World Economic Forums
global agenda council on negotiation and conflict
resolution.
This council is a multi state group of former
heads of state, major actors, negotiators
working to help people deal with their differences
more effectively.
At Davos we've been sharing with the community
here.
Some of the major insights that we've been
working on and practical advice that we are
working to spread around the world in terms
of how to make our world a safer place.
And I think this is really important information
to be sharing.
Basically one year ago the world had very
little sense of the impending global economic
crisis.
And there's consensus among many within the
international security realm, or at least
some that there is another insipient crisis
right around the corner.
And that is the crisis of International security.
How do we keep ourselves safe from terrorism,
from nuclear proliferation and from violent
conflict?
What we've realized is that the nature of
conflict has changed significantly over the
past 15-20 years.
And indeed we've found that there's a lot
more interstate conflict.
Conflict within states, regional conflict
than interstate conflict.
Additionally there's been more fragmentation,
so we're finding increasing division within
rebel movements governments, for example in
the DRC and elsewhere.
And on and on.
A number of different ways that conflict has
changed in our world.
The question though is ultimately, how are
we going to deal with conflict large scale
violent conflict in our world most effectively?
And this is a tough question; there are a
tremendous number of people working hard to
deal with this situation.
Around the world literally.
From our own perspective, a couple of key
points come out.
First of all, there's something we call the
prevention principle.
It's incredibly important for the international
community working in issues of crisis management,
conflict resolution to focus at the smallest
level, most local level possible at the earliest
moment possible.
What can we be doing today to prevent the
immergence of violent conflict in the future?
And who can be doing what now?
We should be pressuring our government leaders
to take action now.
Yes the economy is critically important, but
if we only focus on the economy, then we are
leaving a very fragile world where fragile
states are going to become very chaotic states.
And in this borderless world we will all be
victim to those kinds of complexities of our
world.
Secondly, we've been talking about the importance
of talk, of negotiation.
And it's in many ways obviously important
when people have differences to talk about
those differences, yet it doesn't always happen
in the international spectrum, especially
with so many different kinds of actors, non-state
actors.
And it's our belief -- I'll speak personally,
it's my belief that it's extremely important
to talk, especially to those who you consider
your enemy if your goal is ultimately peace.
And talking in today's world, we've also realized
has its great complexities.
Talking isn't simply picking up a phone anymore,
well it can be, but even picking up a phone
is increasingly a part of the complexity of
negotiation when we have cell phones, when
we have rebel movements in [pause] hard to
reach locations using the cell phone.
Exploiting the use of the cell phone for example.
How can we use technology most effectively
it foster talk.
A third kind -- area that we've been focusing
on within our council is the importance of
bringing women into the peace making process.
There are some, but not many involved in the
peace making process.
The UN has been working to promote that and
we as well are trying to promote the importance
of bringing women into the dialogue process,
into the peacemaking processes.
And finally, this is one that hits me very
close to home. It's the importance of dealing
with emotional and identity based dimensions
to conflict.
Conflict obviously involves conflict resolution
which involves many different elements.
And one of the most important when we have
interstate conflicts and regional conflicts
is how do you deal with these emotional identity
based issues?
We don't have the skills, we don't have the
tools right now to deal with those complexities.
There are certainly people out there doing
good work in this realm.
Those in transitional justice, people doing
work on how to deal with trauma.
But when I look at the situation in Gaza,
it frightens me, and saddens me in so many
ways.
Partially because we don't as a world community
know how effectively to deal with these kinds
of situations.
And it's imperative to develop new ideas,
new practical ideas to deal with them.
That's part of my work at the Harvard International
Negotiation Initiative, what we're doing.
In any case YouTube, I know this was a mouthful,
but I look forward to continued conversations
with you on this subject matter.